what does the mainstream media do of
course of course of course they have to
make you fear everything I don't just is
this just a blip on your radar should we
be thinking we're out of any woods
whatsoever
no and of course the victory for you
know Greg Abbott and Ron DeSantis and
the Texas GOP these places are going to
double down their efforts and and become
even more Laboratories of autocracy to
scale up but I really want today to
honor what has happened and uh one of my
mantras I don't usually say it on this
show because we're talking about you
know threats that await us is never
underestimate the American people
because one of the big takeaways is that
we can have confidence in our election
system and uh and confidence in our own
ability to organize and to affect change
and to be resilient and to have these
wins even under very difficult
circumstances on mainstream media they
will constantly be telling you that
Florida is not free it's an autocracy or
it's fascistic or that's what's
happening in Texas and some of these
other red States and it's like the
proof's in the pudding you can come here
nobody's leaving Anna lives in Miami
Anna I know it's like it says it in your
Twitter bio I'm not outing you you live
in Miami that just got flip read why
don't you leave like why don't you leave
I think we know why you don't you're
enjoying the taxes and you know it's
actually pretty good here